hört bitte auch auf die schüler wenn man
nach revolution ruft glaube ich wäre
nicht der richtige schritt und du bist
nach hinten gegangen weil du dass du
findest es mir zu viel bashing jetzt von
politikern
was denkt ihr bereitet uns die schule
von heute wirklich auf das leben von
morgen vor
ist unser schulsystem noch zeitgemäß
oder ist es zeit ganz neu zu denken neue
fächer neue noten neue chancen für alle
darüber lässt sich wunderbar streiten
und das tun wir immer auf der suche nach
kompromissen in meinen 13 frauen und die
allererste frage geht an ruhig wenn ihr
euch entscheiden könnte wie sehen eure
meinung nach die schule der zukunft wenn
ihr die folgenden fragen mit ja
beantworten würde dann würde ich euch
bitten einen schritt in richtung gelbes
feld zu gehen wenn ihr sagt nee so
stimmt das aber nicht dann bitte einen
schritt richtung grün
soweit alles klar gut 13 fragen hier
kommt frage nummer zwei unser
schulsystem hat sich in seinen
grundpfeilern seit dem 19 jahrhundert
nicht wesentlich verändert wir brauchen
nicht einzelne reformen sondern eine
revolutionierung des ganzen systems
stimmt ihr zu ja heißt ein schritt
richtung gelb nein ein schritt richtung
grün und bitte
ich bin schon mich frustriert dass ein
großteil des unterrichts genauso
aussieht wie damals bei uns aus gesehen
hat wir haben ganz viele
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
aber an die wir ahnen müssen und die
wird nicht leicht ist wir müssen das
curriculum aufräumen und platz schaffen
für neue lerninhalte werden uns streiten
müssen
es wird nicht einfach aber dann müssen
wir jetzt durch ich wünschte mir dass
bildungspolitiker mehr vertrauen in
schulleiterinnen haben und ihnen mehr
handlungsfreiheit gewähren mehr
ressourcen geben in form von freiräumen
und geldern damit sie schnell innovation
vorantreiben können an ihren schulen
hier kommt frage nummer drei lehrer
innen werden aktuell nicht dazu
ausgebildet ihre klassen auf die
herausforderungen des 21 jahrhunderts
vorzubereiten
die ausbildung der lehrer innen muss
also ganz grundsätzlich erneuert werden
stimmt ihr zu
[Musik]
das was im corona shutdown schief
gegangen ist werden die lehrer
verantwortlich gemacht und die lehrerin
das ist ungerecht denn es ist eigentlich
nicht fehler des systems
es fehlten schon vorher lehrkräfte es
fehlte schon vorher raum
es war ein investitionsstau in den
gebäuden und die digitale ausstattung
ist miserabel wir brauchen beste schulen
in unserer in der schwierigsten lage
wenn wir wollen dass auch die ärmeren
kinder gute schule um
chancengerechtigkeit im bildungssystem
erfahren müssen wir deren schulen zur
leuchtturm machen die für alle kinder
dieser stadt attraktiv sind
frage nummer vier noten führen in den
meisten fällen zu ungesundem
leistungsdruck und zu konkurrenzkämpfen
und sollten daher abgeschafft werden
stimmt ihr zu
[Musik]
lukas max bisschen bisschen gut jetzt
sogar ein bisschen aber wir sind ja erst
stimme er zu möchte ich sagen aber du
wirst ganz klar du stimmst offenbar
nicht zu nein ich glaube ein schulsystem
ohne leistungsorientierung kann nicht
funktionieren natürlich geht es darum
letztendlich leistungen zu erbringen
kompetenzen zu erwerben aber wir müssen
den kindern auch helfen dass sie die
erwerben können das heißt wir müssen
auch für starts chancengerechtigkeit
sorgen viel leistungsdruck war ein
extrem großes thema ich habe mich selber
total unter druck gesetzt ohne triftigen
grund aber schon weil ich von der
gesellschaft wirklich gespürt habe es
würde irgendwas rom erwartet was ich
erfüllen soll und habe versucht es ab
biegen und brechen hinzukriegen
unabhängig davon wie es mir auch
psychisch und körperlich dienen wir
haben uns ein bisschen auf dem feld
positioniert am ende ist es auch nicht
so dass wir hier fordern dass zwei
parteien sich die köpfe einschlagen
sondern natürlich muss jeder selber
schauen wo er am ende auf dem feld
landet mein ziel sollte es natürlich
trotzdem seien euch alle wieder zurück
in die mitte quasi auf den boden des
kompromisses zu führen das wäre
natürlich wunderbar ob das klappt mal
sehen zweite runde
frage nummer fünf politik und schulen
haben es in den letzten jahren versäumt
in einem der reichsten länder der welt
chancengleichheit in sachen bildung
herzustellen stimmt ihr zu kommt nach
vorne stimmt ihr nicht zu geht nach
hinten oder bleibt neutral stehen
[Musik]
das ist spannend du bist jetzt schon
fast wieder in der mitte angekommen
peter wiederum ist stehen geblieben
du glaubst wir haben chancengleichheit
oder du glaubst schule und politik
sollen sich den schuh nicht anziehen ich
glaube dass die schule überfordert ist
wenn man von ihr verlangt sie soll
wirklich chancengerechtigkeit herstellen
ich glaube wir können bestimmte
missstände dämpfen aber die illusion
dass wir alles ausgleichen was sie die
gesellschaft dann unterschieden
darstellt und hervorbringt das glaube
ich eine überforderung von schule die
dann leider auch dazu führt dass wir
ständig müsse erfolge verzeichnen es
wird der schule versorgt da hat schule
versorgt wir können nicht alle
unterschiede ausgleichen das wird nicht
funktionieren also ich verstehe mich
richtig schule kann nicht das
ausgleichen was die gesellschaft
verbockt hat nicht alles ausgleichen nur
ein teil
ok nehmen wir mal so hin wir diskutieren
gleich noch in größerer runde weiter so
jetzt gibt's natürlich auch noch einen
vorwurf an die gruppe gelb der lautet
folgendermaßen politik zu bashen ist
sehr einfach aber es gibt ja durchaus
gestaltungsspielraum lehrer/innen
schüler innen und eltern sollten weniger
meckern sondern viel mehr
eigeninitiative ergreifen
[Musik]
max geht sehr zögerlich warum die lehrer
innen zeigen extrem viel engagement
gerade auch in den letzten monaten
natürlich kannst du immer noch mehr
geben aber im moment ist es schon auch
an der politik jetzt mal nachzuziehen
und die grundlagen zu schaffen dass
dieses engagement auch sich verbreitet
und weitergetragen werden kann
ich bin ich ja mal gespannt auch was ihr
dazu sagt ob eure lehrer innen sich
genügend engagieren oder ob ihr eine
andere meinung hat schreibt wie gesagt
alles in kommentare hinein
vielen dank erstmal dafür wir sind immer
noch in runde zwei gewesen und gehen
jetzt in runde drei über
na ja wir haben das thema
chancengleichheit schon mal kurz auf dem
tableau gehabt was ist das richtige
rezept gegen soziale ungleichheit im
deutschen bildungssystem das wird nicht
in einem satz klappen das zu beantworten
ich bin in den 90ern als flüchtling nach
deutschland gekommen
mit 14 und durfte dann im
schnellverfahren innerhalb von vier fünf
jahren deutschland mich anpassen
in einem dieser stadt ankommen und dann
entsprechend auch mein abitur
absolvieren
wo kommst du her ich komme als
bürgerkrieg in bosnien war nicht nach
deutschland kommen und habe da ganz
unterschiedliche erfahrungen gemacht zum
teil waren sie auch sehr positiv sonst
hätte ich jetzt kein abitur ich bin
innerhalb dieses systems aber auch
lehrkräften begegnet die ganz
unterschiedlich mit den
herausforderungen von euch hin
zugewanderten kindern umgehen zwei
beispiele ich bin seit drei monaten in
deutschland bin gerade aus dem bett
kommt klasse in die regelklasse
gewechselt und wir schreiben in der
neunten klasse thema erörterung und das
ist für mich allein schon der begriff
ist hart ich verstehe so zu sagen ich
mein wortschatz ist ganz knapp
ich habe mir aber extrem viel mühe
gegeben und habe verstanden warum es bei
der ortung gehen meine lehrerin hat mir
da nicht zwei plus gegeben und hat mich
von der ganzen klasse gelobt das hat
mich viele jahre danach beflügelt auch
in der phase als sich in eine andere
schule gekommen bin
mit einem deutlich traditioneller ein
system mit weniger blick auf den
einzelnen schüler und dann drei jahre
lang durchgehend drei punkte in deutsch
hatte weil eben meinen wortschatz nicht
so fortgeschritten war unabhängig davon
wie stark ich mich engagiert habe ich
habe in wedding an einer schule
gearbeitet und habe die erfahrung
gemacht jeder dieser schüler hat mehr
potenzial als wir erreichen können wenn
wir wenn er an einer regelschule ist es
geht gar nicht darum dass maximum zu
erreichen
aber es geht viel mehr und deswegen ist
dieser kampf gegen die segregation für
mehr chancengerechtigkeit im system
müssen kernbestandteil dem die uns in
der politik und eben auch lehrkräfte
gemeinsam widmen
bei der frage nach der durchmischung
auch sozialer schichten sagst du ja es
hilft allen schüler innen wenn soziale
schichten durchmischt werden habe ich
dich richtig verstanden
hat sie recht ja recht das hilft
insbesondere uns auch als gesellschaft
schule ist ja nicht nur ein wissens
vermittelnder ort sondern auch im
sozialen lernen dort und dafür ist es
extrem wichtig ich frag mal die lehrerin
im bunde wenn man du bist der lehrerin
und gehst du in der echt so die schaufel
zu infizieren du kennst ja sicherlich
auch die eltern die ich nehme jetzt mal
ein beispiel ist ein klischee beispiel
die wohnen eigentlichen kreuzberg wollen
aber nicht dass ihr kind auf die schule
mit dem hohen migrationshintergrund
kommt deswegen geben sie irgend eine
zweitwohnung in keine ahnung
charlottenburg an so dass das kind dann
auf die vermeintlich bessere schule
gehen darf wie geht man als lehrkraft
mit so was immer ich meine dass begegnet
einem jahr dauern tja also ich denke
wenn unsere schulen besser wären dann
hätten wir das gar nicht ich glaube es
ist sozusagen wir sprechen wieder von
der revolution also wenn wir da besser
an an der wurzel ansetzen würden hätten
wir dieses problem der segregation gar
nicht wenn wir nämlich zum beispiel auf
die kinder wirklich gucken die
potenziale die kinder eines mitbringen
um im leben nicht leistungen ab benutzen
und kategorisieren
dann würde da ganz viel entfaltung
stattfinden in der grundschule schon und
wir hätten eben diese aufsplitterung
nicht in den späteren klassen ich eben
du hast ja offenbar nerv getroffen vor
allem bei den menschen die sowieso schon
auf deiner auf dem feld stehen also ihr
könnt gut kompromisse gerade schließen
wenig überraschend aber warum bist du so
vehement nach vorne gegangen weil ich
absolut den gleichen punkt vertrete ich
finde den schulen grundsätzlich so
ausgestattet sind dass sie aus jedem
einzelnen schüler das beste rausholen
können dann ist es wirklich nicht mehr
so relevant brauchen wir jetzt eine
durchmischung brauchen wir jetzt noch
mehr pädagogen noch mehr psychologen die
frage ist wie erreichen wir dieses ziel
dass individuen dass diese kinder die so
viel mitbringen und potenzial wie man so
schön sagt das auch tatsächlich
entfalten kann
ich finde man muss sowohl bei den
schulen ansetzen und sagen die schulen
müssen besser aufgestellt sein so dass
sie die kinder bestmöglich fördern
aber genauso wichtig ist es dass man
soziale bildung hat dass man eine
durchmischung hat dass man andere
kulturen kennen lernt dass man
aufeinander zugehen kann so wie wir es
hier versuchen genau das ist der ansatz
den teil ich total
und wenn wir eine schule freiheit
in der wahl für eltern aber auch für
lehrerin muss sich aussuchen kann wo man
arbeitet oder wo man seine kids
hinschickt wenn wir die schulen
ermächtigen würden selbst die richtigen
antworten zu finden statt des zentral zu
administrieren
dann hätten wir weniger die das system
unterlaufen müssen also ist es eine
frage von recht das richtig ist es auch
eine würde ist ein bisschen mehr
konkurrenz unter schulen auch wer um
gute schüler bolt ist das habe ich das
richtig verstanden
ja ich habe kein problem mit wettbewerb
ja okay das heißt man das ist ja genau
das also die den zentralismus quasi
beseitigen und jede schule kann um
schüler innen kämpfen und vor allem geht
es auch um die eigenverantwortung der
schulen weil was ich ganz viele leben in
meiner arbeit das heißt wir würden gerne
kann aber nicht weil die da oben ja
unsere schule auf der ich selber war die
hat ganz ganz viel umgesetzt an neuen
strukturen und wir haben nicht immer
großartig gefragt dürfen wir das jetzt
das jetzt regelkonform werden einfach
überlegt was ist das beste für uns
schüler haben wir schüler überlegt die
lehrer mit überlegt die eltern haben mit
überlegt besaß und einem boot weil wir
haben nämlich das selbe ziel wir wollen
junge menschen bestmöglich auf die
zukunft vorbereiten das ist ja das ziel
geht er überzeugt ich dass du stehst
immer noch so ein hype auf den strich
der punkt ist halt das klingt ja gut
konkurrenz und jede schule kämpft
zusammen für die beste lösung bin
überzeugt wenn wir hier zu sagen die
konkurrenz eröffnen bei diesem total
unterschiedlichen bedingungen die wir
haben dann erreichen wir genau das
gegenteil wir erreichen noch mehr
segregation das eben dann die schulen
die was werde ich geringen
migrationsanteil haben die also
bestimmte soziale schichten
bildungsbürgertum repräsentieren noch
mehr zulauf haben und diejenigen das ist
ja immer gerade das problem
es liegt immer an seiner schule mit zum
90 prozent migrationsanteil liegt ja
nicht daran dass die lehrer jetzt da
nicht gut arbeiten oder es liegt dann
nicht unbedingt daran dass die schule
jetzt schlecht ausgestattet ist sondern
es liegt generell an die schlechten
rahmenbedingungen
es ist keine gelegenheit der pausenhof
dann auch beispielsweise deutsch zu
reden
es ist kein kontakt da man bleibt unter
sich
und das ist genau das schwierige was so
problematisch macht da vorwärts zu
kommen
deswegen bin ich nach wie vor auf der
suche ich muss ehrlich sagen nach
lösungen die musterlösungen auch die
konkurrenz jetzt nicht sein
jamila bei dir ist tatsächlich am
kürzesten her dass die schulbank
gedrückt hast du hast letztes jahr abi
gemacht wenn du an unser schulsystem
denkst und wirklich mal versucht auf den
punkt zu kriegen was macht dich am
wütend dass wir nicht alle themen zu
durcheinander mischen oder was ist der
punkt du sagst das müssen wir jetzt
angehen
also was mich persönlich als schülerin
immer am wüten ssten gemacht hat oder
generell als junger mensch oder als als
kind war nicht ernst genommen zu werden
und das ist finde ich was was mich
wütend macht schule ist dass sie oft den
jungen menschen oder den schülern nicht
auf zeigt wie viel handlungsspielraum
sie eigentlich haben wieviel
mitbestimmungsrecht wie viel sie selbst
mitgestalten dürfen
ich finde da müssten alle parteien
lehrer eltern politiker auch auf die
schüler zu gehen können und ihnen
ermöglichen ihr seid mit gefragt nicht
umsonst habe ich mit 14 jahren mit zwei
kolleginnen ein buch geschrieben die 13
14 15 waren zu dritt weil wir gesagt
haben wir werden uns jetzt auch mal zu
wort wir sind schließlich die
betroffenen und unsere stimme muss auch
gehört werden und was heißt das dann in
konsequenz für schulsystem das ist die
forderung die forderung ist hört bitte
auch auf die schüler und was sie fordern
was sie sich vorstellt meyer warum hört
die politik so wenig auf die schüler ja
ich habe das gefühl wir bewegen uns
genau in die richtung die gewünschte ist
wir reden mit allen gehen die richtigen
schritte und es wird hat nicht immer
gesehen dass nach warum wird es nicht
gesehen warum kommt es so wenig an weil
wir bewegen alleine berlin anker mit
50.000 beschäftigten und 350.000
schülerinnen und schüler und am ende
springt man immer von der einen politik
und das heißt sie bringen etwas auf dem
weg aber die idee von einer
eigenverantwortlichen schule
das ist eine entwicklung der letzten
zehn jahre sie muss aber durchsickern
die einzelnen standorte das heißt wir
haben an schumi schwieriger lage haben
wir sagen wir mal ein drittel der
standorte die sind großartig sie sind
innovativ zu sagen wir haben eigene
profile und die sind dann auch durch
nicht weil die schülerinnen zu ihnen
kommen das ist nämlich das der schlüssel
rezept gibt den menschen ressourcen und
gebt den freiheit und die machen das
aber wir brauchen noch zeit weil eben
wir wollen dass für alle standorte
wollen und ich widerspreche ganz klar
dem punkte in der abwägung zwischen muss
man mehr ausstattung an schulen in
schwieriger lage geben wird es reicht es
jedem schüler gerecht zu werden ohne
mehr ausstattung werden bei den schülern
nicht gerecht und daher sozusagen ist
dass sie mal zwei bei sozusagen zwei
standpunkte das eine es gibt die
freiheit aber ohne mehr ausstattung wird
es nicht gehen
mich würde interessieren was peter dazu
sagt hat hat sie recht die politik tut
das richtige nur das dauert halt ein
bisschen also also ich sage immer und
das meine wirklich und ist nicht so
einfach als lehrer verband so was zu
sagen ich möchte oft nicht in der haut
von politikern stecken weil natürlich
die erwartungshaltung riesig ist und
selbst wenn das guthaben wird
wahrscheinlich nicht so viel lob zurück
kommen deswegen ist glaube ich auch
wichtig dass man die fortschritte die es
gibt auch anerkennt ja muss man sagen
auch als lehrer gewerkschaften müssten
fortschritte auch anerkennen was nicht
heißt dass man nicht auch den nur noch
nicht in die wunde legt ich konnte gut
was du gesagt dass famila ernst nehmen
schüler ernst nehmen ja also ich glaube
dass das auch ganz zentraler punkt im
bildungssystem wie ernst genommen ist es
sind die individuen die lehrer genauso
vom staat wie die schüler was mich nur
darüber bin der älteste
ich bin eine schule gekommen darüber
wirklich der schüler schüler meinung
nicht muss man sagen das war in der
mittelstufe in der 68er zeit und da war
es die diskussion auf augenhöhe oder
sowas das heißt eigentlich ist ja heute
dieser konflikt zwischen lehrern und
schülern ist ja gar nicht da aber ich
würde mir natürlich wünschen dass viel
mehr schüler sich langfristig auch
politisch oder auch in der schule
engagieren die möglichkeiten gibt
die hatten wir damals dich aber jetzt
sind sie da marie ist dies eigentlich
viel besser als ihr ruf
manche ja das gefühl alle alle weisen
lässt dann ständig über das schulsystem
aber ja ich die politik tut schon vieles
dauert ein bisschen
der peter sagt ja das stimmt die politik
macht das gar nicht so schlecht bei uns
war früher alles noch viel schlimmer
jetzt ist alles irgendwie besser anders
sagen natürlich dinge natürlich gibt es
schulen an denen die arbeit sehr gut
läuft und schüler sehr ernst genommen
werden die gibt es und es gibt ganz
tolle pilotschulen und leuchttürme nach
denen man sich an denen man sich
orientieren sollte ich glaube aber dass
ernst nehmen von schülerinnen und
schülern funktioniert nur wenn wir im
system veränderungen schaffen weil das
machtgefälle zwischen lehrer und schüler
ist einfach da und das kann man mit
notengebung und ich sage also wenn du
verletzt bist oder nicht und ich sagte
ja auch was du zu lernen hast den
bundles zu lassen wollen wir die
klassenarbeit schreiben und so weiter
und so fort funktioniert nicht dann
fühlen sich die schüler nicht erst
gesichert da werden auch einige und von
den menschen die gerade dieses video
sehen werden wahrscheinlich sagen ja
moment mal das klingt mir alles hierzu
net also wenn ich in die schule gehe
dann erlebe ich das mutmaßlich anders
aber was genau bedeutet dass
systemveränderung in die fernschüler
mehr mitsprachrecht schüler dürfen
selber entscheiden wann die
klassenarbeit geschrieben oder ob es
eine geschrieben vielleicht gibt gar
keine
vielleicht gibt es ja jetzt dass der
unglücklich pro können wir konkret also
was kann man den controller aber für
mich an also was mir fehlt in der
diskussion häufig ist so dass rang
hangeln von moment zu moment brauchen
wir die 45 minuten stunde brauchen wir
nicht noch mehr inklusion brauchen wir
nicht noch mehr digitalisierung sind
alles irgendwie so päckchen die drauf
geladen werden über die wir einzelne
diskutieren ich glaube wir müssen ganz
ganz grundsätzlich man überlegen was
schülerinnen und schüler heutzutage
wirklich erleben sollen und ich sage
ganz ausdrücklich erleben und lernen an
schulen was sie erfahren sollen damit
sie die zukunft aktiv mutig neugierig
gestalten weil wir werden in der zukunft
noch krasseren herausforderungen
begegnen müssen als das was wir im
letzten halbjahr erlebt haben und dafür
sind unsere jugendliche ich sag mal in
der fläche nicht vorbereitet
und das macht mir angst du hast sogar
recht angst du du bist wütend du wirst
ängstlich und was weißt du ich bin auch
wütend darüber dass wir das immer noch
nicht geschafft haben das lernen das
selbstständige lernen zu stärken sondern
dass wir immer noch wieder punkte setzen
wo noten wo zeugnisse kommen wo
klassenarbeiten kommen die den
schülerinnen schülern sagen nein das
hast du alles nicht gut gemacht anstatt
sie zu zum selbstständigen lernen zu
ermutigen also immer das zu
dokumentieren was jemand nicht kann also
das macht mich wütend ich würde gern ein
thema noch ansprechen jetzt das noch gar
nicht zur sprache kam wirklich weltweit
gerade viel diskutiert wird stichwort
digitalisierung marie es gibt ja
tatsächlich manche schulen in
deutschland die haben weder ein konzept
zur digitalen wissensvermittlung noch
wlan
das fängt ja manchmal bei basalen sachen
an andere schulen ärgern sich noch nicht
mehr über fehlendes wlan sondern darüber
dass sie keine funktionierenden
toiletten haben auch das gibt es wie
sieht denn die schule der zukunft im
thema digitalisierung aus einst so wo
wir hingehen also wo es sein wie die
schule aussehen sollte was ein gen sei
der hinweis digitalisierung laptops für
alle laptops brauchen wir nicht mehr die
sind schon aus dem letzten jahr nein das
ist eine echte aufgabe für die zukunft
von vorgestern bis hin in die zukunft
weil sich auch alles rasant verändert
das was du gerade gesagt dass laptops
sind also in zehn jahren werden wir
wahrscheinlich mit dem laptop arbeiten
sondern weiß ich nicht mit tablets keine
ahnung gesagt wahrscheinlich auch keine
e mails schreiben
es verändert sich so rasant dass wir uns
das noch gar nicht richtig vorstellen
könnte ist ja auch eine frage von
residenz ich meine ich finde es geht gar
nicht darum kann ich jetzt ein
smartphone oder ein tablet bedienen oder
nicht die frage ist wie kann ich mit
veränderung um mehr in und das müsste in
schulen gelernt werden und zwar sowohl
für die lehrer als auch für die schüler
ich meine ich weiß nicht was in zehn
jahren noch für geräte auf mich zukommt
von den ich jetzt noch keine ahnung habe
ich werde das lernen müssen und ich
werde mir zutrauen müssen dass ich es
lernen kann
max du hast eine zum thema
vernetzungen wissenstransfer und
digitalisierung du hast eine plattform
gegründet lehrer marktplatz de dass
tatsächlich eine privatwirtschaftlich
organisierte plattform wo menschen
lehrer und lehrerinnen sich
unterrichtsmaterialien austauschen
können und für kleines geld abkaufen
können das ganze ist lukrativ damit
beschäftigt du einige mitarbeiter und
was sagt das über die
innovationsbereitschaft des deutschen
schulsystems aus dass das
privatwirtschaftlich organisiert ist das
ist sagt erst mal was über die
lehrkräfte aus ja das sind 450.000 40
prozent der deutschsprachigen lehrkräfte
auf dieser plattform jeden tag kommen
1000 dazu wir haben kein problem dass
die lehrkräfte das internet verabscheuen
die wollen das nutzen die tauschen sich
aus millionen downloads jeden monat das
zeigt auch noch was zweites es gibt eine
infrastruktur thema wo wir die schulen
ausstatten müssen und da würden wir uns
wünschen dass die gelder ein bisschen
schneller fließen okay und dann haben
wir nur einen haken an die
eintrittskarte digitalisierung ist
vielmehr ist auch umgang von schülern
mit digitalen lernen ist nicht den
unterricht digital über den smartphone
machen
das wird wahrscheinlich nie geben aber
es gibt ganz viele prozesse im
hintergrund wir machen ja nur den der
unterrichtsvorbereitung es gibt die
unterrichts nachbereitung es gibt
feedback systeme die fehlen und schulen
es gibt kommunikationssysteme die die
eltern mit einbinden können es gibt ganz
viel digitalität die wir in den letzten
10 20 jahren in anderen bereichen erlebt
haben die im schuljahr ablauf noch nicht
vorkommen und da ist ein riesengroßer
hebel der das arbeiten an schulen besser
machen kann der die elternschaft mehr
integrieren kann der auch schüler mehr
zu wort kommen lassen kann
ja er war wohl ab welchen knopf müsste
man drücken also wem würdest du gerne
als ihnen beitreten also ich finde da
passiert auch einiges was was erst sehr
langsam passiert ist die vorstellung
dass auch ein kommerzielles unternehmen
im bildungsbereich existieren darf eine
sache die passiert ist durch corona ist
dass ganz viele lehrkräfte in ihrer
selbstwahrnehmung einen schub bekommen
haben weil sie ausprobieren mussten ging
ja gar nicht anders und zwar 17 tools
gleichzeitig und dass die jetzt mutiger
geworden sind
und ich glaube auch immer mehr verlangen
werden dass es arbeitserleichterung
systeme gibt man auch wenn dir mal eine
klassenfahrt und treibt das geld ein das
wird alles noch mit zetteln und
irgendwas gemacht da geht noch so viel
und ich glaube bat da ist meine hoffnung
dass wir da am anfang von der revolution
stehen
peter als vertreter der eines
lehrerverbandes hat er recht am anfang
einer revolution
er hatte recht das glaube ich ist
tatsächlich die zukunft wir reden viel
zu viel über technik und zu wenig über
diesen pädagogischen mehrwert wenn zonen
digital gestützte präsenzunterricht mal
wirklich gut funktioniert bin ich voll
dabei verlieren wenn wir dann sagen wir
wollen nicht zurück zum regelbetrieb
weil der suggeriert sowas rückständiges
sondern zum glück sind wir zurück zu
mehr präsenz bei guter unterricht
braucht die präsenz und jetzt lasst uns
das gelernte mitnehmen lass uns da eine
reise starten in der unterstützung in
der prozess digitalität dann dann haben
wir echt eine chance an diesem tag zu
kommen
wir wollen nicht sagen dass es digitales
lernen ist sondern dieses lernen mit
digitalen medien ist dass soziales
lernen ist gemeinsames lernen ist
selbstständiges lernen
das wollen wir unser digital unterstützt
ja aber so viele stellen sich vor nur
das digitale gerät und nein nein ich
muss auch kinder die keinen nicht gerne
lernen die muss sich auch mit motivieren
mit einem digitalen gerät zu lernen oder
medienkompetenz zu entwickeln also
medienkompetenz entwickeln ist eben
total wichtig und unserer gesellschaft
und das hilft uns eben auch nie
ob ein lehrkraft ersetzen ja aber es
werden digitale systeme lehrkräfte
besser machen indem sie tun
wir sind alles recht eng zusammengerückt
ich würde gerne in unserer
abschlussrunde gehen da sind wir also
auf der suche nach kompromissen schulen
brauchen mehr autonomie mehr freiheit
sie sollen mehr als bisher über gelder
entscheiden dürfen über lehrpläne neue
lehrinhalte und neue fächer stimmt ihr
zu frage nummer 12 bildungspolitiker
innen werden verpflichtet regelmäßig in
schulen zum beispiel an schulkonferenzen
teilzunehmen
also quasi kontakt zur basis zu halten
findet ihr das gut
peter ja du somit und
bildungspolitikerin sagen weil er mal
kurz blick auf mein terminkalender nein
bei aller liebe dreimal also wenn wir
etwas machen ist an der basis seien die
unterstellung dahinter an sozusagen das
ist der detail wo ich ganz klar
widersprechen
also wenn ich etwas tue ist bitte basis
reden ferner du sagst trotzdem ja du
hast du würdest du mehr wünsche über
mehr politiker und schulen kommen würden
nicht nur um preise zu vergleichen
sondern auch mal um missstände und zu
gucken genau und nicht nur eine stunde
sondern auch mal einen ganzen tag
wahrnehmen war eine stunde kann auch
eine schule dann sich positiv darstellen
weil wenn die bildungsministerin kommt
möchte man auch nicht doof da stehen
also die brauchen schon bisher mehr und
sollten gerne genau wissen was los ist
und du bist nach hinten gegangen weil du
dass du findest ist mir zuviel bashing
jetzt von politikern ja interessant also
mehr so aus solidarität als ich würde
jetzt sagen das sind jetzt unterstellt
dass die politiker nicht wieso man in
schulen los ist und das kann ich so
nicht unterschreiben
du hast mein herz gewonnen ja jetzt
kommen wir ganz am ende also zur frage
nummer 13 und die geht wieder an die
community ihr habt jetzt viel gehört
viele lösungsvorschläge liegen hier auf
dem tisch bzw auf dem feld wie kann
schule besser zukunftsträchtiger werden
vielleicht sogar noch mehr spaß machen
als sie ist sowieso schon tot schreibt
es uns bitte in die kommentare und ganz
herzlichen dank an euch alle
vielen vielen dank
ja es war eine schöne diskussion hat
spaß gemacht die verschiedenen
standpunkte zu erfahren und wir haben ja
im endeffekt ein ganz tollen kompromiss
eigentlich gefunden oder viele
kompromisse bei vielen punkten und ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir das abbilden
jetzt bei schule und zukunft der bildung
na gut das war heute keine 16
bildungsminister und auch keine 16
finanzminister deswegen glaube ich wird
es noch ein bisschen dauern bis man die
erkenntnisse auch in die wirklichkeit
umgesetzt
ich wünsche schülern die jetzt in die
schule kommen die jetzt in die schule
gehen die noch in dieser schule drin
sind dass sie sich nicht auf die schule
beschränken und nicht sagen die schule
wird mein leben bestimmen und selbst
auch die verantwortung für ihr wirken
übernehmen und nicht sagen die schule
erlaubt mir das nächste aufgrund der
schule darf ich das nicht selber aktiv
werden das wünsche ich mir für schüler
und dass sie wissen dass das dürfen und
dass sie dazu in der lage sind
[Musik]
wir freuen uns mit euch zu diskutieren
hier könnt ihr unseren kanal abonnieren
hier oben gibt es ein weiteres video zum
thema und hier eine weitere folge 13
fragen
[Musik]